make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I was talking to a buddy of mine
Adam earlier today and he and I were
talking about like what'll happen at the
end of Avengers 4 right because like
Avengers 4 is probably the most
anticipated kind of book movie of all
time I firmly believe that by and large
like Avengers 4 will do more to set set
the stage for what comes after in phase
4 and then like any of the movies that
come after Avengers 4 because Avengers 4
is not the last movie in phase 3 we have
like a couple more movies before we go
in to face for it and I feel like
Avengers 4 will set the stage for all
that and I want to talk about the x-men
and Avengers 4 and then going into face
4 but before we do that I want to kind
of provide you guys with a bit of
information here based on what Marvel
will most likely do when it come our
well cinematic universe will most likely
do when it comes to rolling the x-men
over and putting them in the MCU so in
Marvel Comics what you have is something
called the ultimate universe and the
ultimate universe was an answer to the
question what would happen if
superheroes existed in the Marvel
Universe in the real world right now and
that's why the Marvel Cinematic Universe
with the exception of a couple different
things is so heavily based on the
Ultimate Universe because it's really
the best source of material to go with
for the most part if you want an updated
telling of superheroes and the Ultimate
Universe what you had is you had Nick
Fury black Nick Fury like Samuel Jackson
Nick Fury who was the original super
soldier not Captain America not Steve
Rogers instead what had happened was
that during the during like the events
that that were leading up to world war
ii that what happened was Nick Fury was
basically bonded with the Super Soldier
Serum and then escaped around the same
time that that happened another guy
named James Howlett was taken to Canada
and he was experimented on as well
but when the experiments were happening
with James Howlett what happened is they
basically learned that James had had a
gene inside of him that if it was
activated would grant him powers and
when they activated that gene it gave
him a healing factor and that's how
James Howlett became will reign in the
Ultimate Universe now James Howard
eventually went on did his own thing you
know kind of went out in roamed and you
know whatever but for Nick Fury he
basically escaped when underground and
nobody could find him and so following
that they said well then we need a new
super soldier and so they found Steve
Rogers they bonded the serum to him and
then he went forward as Captain America
so technically in the Ultimate Universe
Captain America is the second person to
receive the Super Soldier Serum not the
first and so following that because of
the fact that like knowledge of this
gene and how to activate it existed in
the hands of like the Canadian
government and in turn became kind of
like this little secret so to speak of
like their government and
powers-that-be eventually what they did
is they took this substance that
activates these genes they synthesized
it and then spread it throughout the
world and what it did is it activated
all of these quote-unquote
X genes inside all these people across
the world and those X genes started
activating and that's where mutants came
that's what mutants showed up that's
basically how we got mutants in the
Ultimate Universe and that's probably
what they'll do in in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe assume that Captain
America dies at the end of Avengers 4
everybody's gonna say okay we need more
super soldiers or some some places
something will rise up or something like
that but we'll basically learn like the
ability to essentially wake up these
genes that like Wolverines been there
the entire time and the ability to wake
up these genes exist and they'll use
that and they'll spread it across the
world and the mutants will start popping
up and like the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that seems to be the most
logical way to do it the easiest and the
simplest way to do it then there's my
theory which i think is a little more
complicated but actually better so
though so in Marvel Comics in the main
Marvel Universe moving away from the
ultimate universe and looking at like
the main Marvel Comics universe what you
had is a program called weapons plus and
weapons Plus was basically this kind of
umbrella company it was this overarching
project and then under that you had
weapon one weapon to weapon three weapon
four all the way up to like weapon ten
which is technically where it ended
although you do have like weapon 12
please like that you got like phantom X
and so on and so forth but the idea
behind this was that due to a set of
events that was very very weird and very
very strange and involved a bacterial
entity named John Sablan that we don't
need to go into essentially like John
sublime came to the conclusion the
mutants were a credible threat and so
what he did is he essentially like
implemented weapons Plus and what
weapons plus dead is a created weapon
one project rebirth Captain America and
the basis behind Captain America's
creation was to create or I guess to to
provide a Super Soldier Serum to a
handful of individuals or to like you
know I guess the standing army and then
see it like used them as a means to like
containing control the mutant threat and
so effectively like world war ii was a
testing ground for Captain America the
problem was in the comics Captain
America was frozen in ice for however
long and they believed he was dead and
so because of the fact that around the
same time that happened or at least
before that happened Abraham Erskine the
guy who invented the Super Soldier Serum
died what it meant was that weapons Plus
was left with nothing
they had no super soldier and they had
no Super Soldier Serum and so following
that there was weapons Plus which
continued on and started creating things
like what
- you know two through ten basically so
like like Frank Simpson like Wolverine
different things like that and then in
turn there were like some follow-up
projects so like Weapon 11 Weapon 12 11
13 so you had like Emma Frost who is a
super powerful telepath and then like
choose clone four times and that gave us
the Stepford cuckoos who were basically
like these girls these four girls who
were clones of Emma Frost and had a kind
of telepathic hive mind meaning if they
combine their minds together they were
more powerful than they were
individually but like they're all these
little projects were working on but
they're also side projects there were
other attempts to to recreate the Super
Soldier Serum in addition to like all
the projects that weapons Plus was
working on right like that's why it's a
big umbrella thing and what you had was
a guy named a professor who basically
created the serum that was like a
thousand times more powerful than the
Super Soldier Serum and then this guy
Robert Reynolds took the serum and then
became a sensory so like that's how
little things kind of fit in but what
you basically say here is that like the
entirety the entire basis behind Captain
America's creation was rooted in like an
effort to do good right like the
strategic scientific reserve
so Chester Phillips who is played by
Tommy Lee Jones at Avengers one Peggy
Carter Howard Stark like they created
the SSR and their bases was creating a
super soldier who could basically fight
on the side of the Allies to rally the
troops and defeat the Axis powers gun it
was basically all based on on doing good
things just like we saw in Captain
America the First Avenger then what you
do is you take Captain America the
Winter Soldier and you take that
information and you roll it in and what
you basically say is after Captain
America was frozen in ice and he was
believed to have been dead and then once
Hydra infiltrated shield and then
started taking it over that what Hydra
did is they basically modified the
entire basis behind weapons Plus as it
was created by SSR and what you say is
Hydra started moving it towards creating
weapons that could be used for like
assassination controlling the people or
something along those lines which is how
you get like fringe Simpson nuke and all
that kind of cool stuff but what you
basically say is like Hydra created
Wolverine you know you had Team X which
is a black ops team a wet work team that
worked for the CIA when Hydra under the
communal controlling shield realize that
Team X existed like Wolverine Sabretooth
Silver Fox maverick did they took Team X
and they threw them into weapons plus as
Weapon X as the 10th version of the
weapon program and then like bonded
adamantium to Wolverine skeleton and
bonded adamantium to Sabretooth skeleton
and then like Wolverine escaped his
captivity and then just ran out into the
world and whatever like that's literally
what you do like you basically say like
all that stuff all that stuff happens
and
the way that you that you essentially
kind of reveal that is one of course
with like the introduction of the x-men
but to you have Captain America recreate
shield at the end of Avengers four
because what what ended up happening
like one of the things you guys remember
from Captain America the Winter Soldier
is that Captain America and Nick Fury
butted heads right because like Nick
Fury was like well you know we have all
these things that we're doing you know
the Captain America is like this isn't
freedom this is fearing all kind of
stuff but the idea was that there was a
point where Nick Fury said no one can
spill all the secrets because no one has
them all that is compartmentalization
that Nick Fury is the only one that has
all that information out there with
Hydra basically showing that an
infiltrated shield and then Captain
America the Winter Soldier basically
being a movie that saw shield completely
dissolved and taken down that in the
aftermath of Avengers 4 Captain America
recreates it says like you know somebody
needs to run shield or somebody goes him
and says like somebody else shield has
to be recreated somebody has to run it
that's you Captain America you're gonna
be the one to run shield that basically
Captain America runs the whole thing but
as part of being able to run it
effectively he has to know all the
secrets of shield and so like it's um
ten minute segments in event at the end
of Avengers four or something like that
or some five minute segment you
basically have Captain America going
through like you're like all the files
of shield and then coming across one
that says like project rebirth slash
weapons Plus and because he knows
project rebirth is the name of the
Captain America project he investigates
and that's when it basically starts
throwing in names like Wolverine and
stuff like that so this is actually like
we have Wolverine in the MCU it's some
small little segment like that is
literally how you pull that off and so
over the course of like the x-men being
put in the Marvel Cinematic Universe you
basically have this kind of like
exploration of what weapons plus is and
how deep it goes you move away from the
comic source material and what you
basically say is like weapons Plus was
the basis behind the creation of the
century Robert Reynolds weapons plus was
the basis behind the creation of like
Hyperion that weapons plots created like
all these major powerhouses
so you don't have to bring them in from
alternate realities you don't have to do
things like invoke the beyonders or like
the negative zone or something like that
you don't do any of that stuff
weapons Plus created all these guys and
like they've been frozen like they've
been kept on ice that when shield
believed that like they were in total
control like when when Captain America
the Winter Soldier happened they were
all just kind of kept on ice in the same
way Bucky Barnes was until they needed
to use them like or they just proved to
be so powerful that [ __ ] that that Hydra
couldn't contain them too they just kept
them frozen and like we've never seen or
heard from them because they've
literally just been sitting in like a
frozen tubes somewhere down in some
basement in some shoddy building
somewhere but you
literally pull all that off and then
just say like by whatever manner and
whatever means they're woken up over
time like I think my theory is better
like I think my idea behind introducing
the x-men into the MCU is better even if
it's a little more complicated but still
like I like that idea like I think it's
awesome like weapons plus all that kind
of stuff because what you basically have
Captain America realizes like the entire
basis behind its creation while it was
rooted and good it was like co-opted by
Hydra and it was twisted and it was
screwed up which now gives Captain
America a reason to like track down
Wolverine but it builds a kind of
mystery and intrigue there that like
Captain America can investigate on his
own or with the help of like Black Widow
or something along those lines or even
like Hawkeye or whatever but I don't
know let me know you guys think down in
the comments section I think it's a cool
idea but if you guys are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys are
the sub button to become part of the
robb for if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and it will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you